welcome to the next 25 i'm your host
dwyane wade and today i get an
opportunity to talk about the future
with some of the games brightest and
best
from uconn plays with the minnesota lynx
please welcome the beautiful
nafissa collier hello hey smooth brother
right here what up good to see you plays
for the indiana pacers tyrese
halliburton
everybody if they don't know this man
right here he went to florida state
plays for the toronto raptors scottie
barnes
born and raised in new york
plays with the new york knicks how you
doing you good ob top
today we want to have conversations
about
fashion
money media
the future of the game
and everything in between welcome guys
thank you for coming here and meeting me
to talk about the neck 25
so something that's very important in
the world that we all are in is this
thing called media i guess i'm now a
part of the media
which just feels weird for me
former players get on tv and you kind of
criticize the players that's playing
does that make you feel a certain way
like they're hating or do you take that
as
you know what they know what they're
talking about
let me do x y z i would much rather get
criticized by a player than like a
commentator and you need that criticism
to spark like especially in our league
we're new you know we want people to
talk about us so like criticism is good
for us
you know what i mean so like when you
have controversy it creates like people
love that it's like reality tv you know
they like more that more than watching
so i think that's good and i'd rather
them speculate about what i'm doing than
like someone who doesn't play that's
what we look for for vets and and and
other players to talk to us and tell us
what we need to work on to to get better
but like i feel like like your team is
all you got like everybody there they're
there because they're trying to win and
and i feel like that's all you got to
worry about you don't need to worry
about all the extra stuff that's going
on on social media or like what people
are trying to say because like only
people working and fighting and seeing
each other every day are the people on
your team so that's that's how i take it
so you guys don't mind when chuck says
something may not pronounce your name
right or don't know who you are or like
that like those things it it doesn't rub
you the wrong way you take that as pot
like constructive criticism i think
there's a line though okay talk about
that there's definitely a line like well
that's that is like one of my biggest
pet peeves though when like a a player
who has been through and seen what guys
go through goes in the media and says
something like he's never been there
before you know what i'm saying like i
think us as athletes we're in the
background like we know
more things than than the regular you
know than the media does and so for the
people who do know more things to still
go up there and act like they don't and
say some crazy things that bothers me
sometimes you got something you wanna
get off your chest up no no nothing
about me nothing about me
coming over there how about something
no but you know the go-to line though
the go-to line that bothers me is like
he wouldn't succeed in my era
what are we talking about
how do you guys like the ability to be
able to now control your own narratives
i think that's the best part about the
league is that we get
to control our you know the narrative
around us and write articles or or or
sit down with one-on-ones in the media
or post on instagram or whatever the
case may be to where you get to control
that a little bit historically we've
seen
media companies and journalists break
news uh or be the first to inform us now
we're seeing players say no i'm good i
got that i can do it myself hey i'm tj
atishola the head of global content
partnerships at twitter
it's cool to see these players take
their platforms and own them in ways
that allow them to share their stories
in ways that allow them to tell what
their convictions are in ways that allow
them to to really assert their platforms
you can control your own narratives but
sometimes on social media
they take a toll people already have
like some type of image of you or
because they do their background
research or whatever so you can't show
who you want to be but sometimes social
media can take a different toll on
what other platforms you think you guys
can use and utilize me personally i
stream i i love video games so i'll hop
on twitch with the game and and have the
mic and my headphones on viewers can
come in and ask me questions and we
could talk about you know the game the
other day or
we could talk about how i'm feeling
about certain things and and that's
that's what you feel comfortable sharing
i feel like i want to get into it's like
a man
but i don't know i i'd be so like i'd be
like i might do it today i'm gonna break
it
just do it and i'll be like nah today
it's not that i don't know how busy like
i'm trying to do that too
what part is scary i don't know i don't
know i just i don't are you aware that
what you say is
is gospel that is
it goes out to the world it's an
interview yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah in that moment while you're
playing the game you at home and someone
asks you a question you're aware that
yeah i'm just not gonna say no i'm just
not gonna say nothing crazy
game though right like big games
somebody made you mad but i mean if you
if you cuss at the g if you cuss at the
game i mean that but that's who you if
that's who you are that's who you are
you know what i'm saying right i'm
thinking we i mean but i think as
athletes i think we all know like if i
get asked a question about something
that i shouldn't be talking about
i'm just gonna ignore it athletes have
always understood the opportunity to
engage fans directly what we're seeing
is fans are now having these amazing
opportunities
to engage
and respond back to their favorite
players as well it's fascinating
it's created this connectivity that has
never existed in sports as a fan i might
have the opportunity to see my favorite
player based off of a tweet that i
respond to that's pretty cool and these
young players really understand the
potency in that and they're using it to
to build and
strengthen their platform how has social
media changed the way you consume games
like
do you consume live or do you just go on
and get your
one minute clip and be like okay i see
what went on in nba like has it changed
the way you guys have consumed watching
live games i feel like it changed the
way that fans
like because they only see the
highlights so like then they put all
their hype behind that one person it's
like
you know what i mean like true
basketball people like you'll know who
the really good players are but they
promote like certain people in the media
or they just put highlight reels like
you don't know really who's good anymore
because they're only posting highlight
reels consumption habits have changed in
a way that consumers may not be picking
up the remote control to watch a three
hour game however they're consuming it
in feed and they're consuming a lot of
it i don't necessarily think that people
have less of an affinity for longer form
content i think that they just have way
more options to consume the content so
they're consuming just as much content
just across a whole bunch of different
platforms and they're doing it envy
they're catching all the highlights
they're catching all the scores and
catching the wins and losses and just
doing it in different ways and not
necessarily holding that remote control
or looking at the box score in a
newspaper like like some of us old old
folks were back in the day let's talk
about virtual reality
are we sitting at home
watching the games with headsets on at
the crib
in the future in the future is
is that where we're going are we going
to sitting at the crib on our couch
putting on the headsets i feel like we
courtside i'm not going to lie down
that'd be pretty pretty cool i don't
know how they're going to do it though
they're going to put the cameras at the
game i don't know but that would be
crazy though it's like you on the court
with them that would be i don't like
that
i don't like it what you don't like
i just feel like
i feel like technology obviously is
awesome but it's taking away like so
many personal experiences like going to
games don't you guys remember that like
when you're little like it's such a cool
experience i don't want to be just like
sitting on the couch and like you take a
picture from the outside and everyone's
just like staring at um glasses like
that's just so creepy to me i don't know
like that's what this panda been doing
though just having people yeah just
sitting at home that's why i feel like
all these things are like being brought
as a new new for us because we just been
sitting at home because of the pandemic
so we we just got to find ways to do
stuff at one point in the pandemic we
were watching trey young shoot dirty
socks into a heifer and we watched that
on social and that's all we had and we
were watching it over and over and over
again and as the pandemic started to
progress it then turned into seeing
players jump into live social audio
rooms we launched something called
twitter spaces we've seen kevin durant
actually have direct conversation with
fans
on the couch on twitter in a live audio
room so we're seeing media evolve uh as
rapid as it's ever been but the pandemic
certainly forced us to to communicate in
ways that we hadn't expected prior to i
mentioned audio spaces i think that's
going to be a feature that is firmly
embedded in the way social media evolves
but even furthermore we're seeing the
metaverse pop up all over the place
imagine a world where
you're in the metaverse with your
favorite player and he dunks on you
right like
there's no shortage to the possibility
that may exist as we think about the
proliferation of nfts and the
development of all things metaverse just
imagine just sitting there on your couch
with with the things on it's like you
right there front view
let's go
i think like you said nothing is ever
going to compare to like
actually being at the game you know what
i'm saying the real experience but i do
think that as an alternative for for
fans i i like it i think people are
definitely going to utilize it and it's
just and it also you know it's another
revenue stream for the league so
more money more money they've been they
do like crazy things too where it's like
you're with other people people like to
watch and consume sports with their
homies but with people that they have an
affinity for everybody's talking about
vr ar especially as it relates to
basketball because basketball's such a
beautiful sport i think the part that
people really really desire that doesn't
quite exist yet is the community
component right if i'm gonna watch a
game or if i'm gonna experience
kd doing something epic or lebron doing
something epic i need to like elbow my
homie and say did you did you see that
did that just happen and today that
doesn't quite exist my friend been
telling me about it like they have like
other people there with you and like a
world with you so you look to the left
you look to the right it's like people
are right there so it's like that's
that's a crazy thing but like do you got
to be like you got to be on the same
channel with something like how does
that work how does someone walk into
your
moment i just know they i don't know
probably you
like gta or something it's like a whole
bunch of people in your lobby you get
you get people to come to the arena
basically like everybody come in the
lobby and then you see if ty's in my
lobby like i could say what's up to todd
through the goggles and it's like like
that that would be tough if the nba come
to you guys and say hey
we want this to be the future of the nba
i'm i'm promoting it you're promoting
what happens if people stop showing up
to your games because they can see it
way better right here than at the top of
the they are getting traffic
to be the same
entertainment that they're gonna be
watching i'm gonna promote it to be the
second option oh
so
i'm going i'm promoting it
there's something special about being in
a live
sporting event i don't think anything
will ever supersede that i do think
there will be things that supplement
that to a certain degree fans want deep
participatory experiences they want to
be able to watch a game and hear
commentary from a player like draymond
green in real time they want to engage
in ways that haven't existed in the past
that may mean i'm responding to
q and a's from a player tweet it might
mean i'm hopping into a live audio space
room it might mean that i'm watching a
live broadcast that's hosted by actual
players and maybe not traditional
broadcasters but one thing is for sure
fans are really eager and they yearn for
that deep participatory exchange and
we're seeing companies and broadcasters
understand that and lean into it and the
future is
probably some
mishmash of the metaverse and nfts and
direct communication participatory
live viewing experiences and players are
going to continue to lean in and fans
will obviously continue to lean in but
there is certainly no no ceiling on the
opportunity that exists for this fan and
player engagement to continue to develop
and evolve